un rail de train et quelques centaines
de mètres de terrain vague
c'est ce qui sépare le village de
castagnès des migrants massés derrière
des barbelés dans ce qu'on appelle ici
la grée zones la zone tampon entre la
grèce et la turquie dans ce petit bourg
rural du nord de la grèce
la décision du président r doan d'ouvrir
ses frontières au passage des migrants
est venu briser la quiétude des
habitants sous les jours le ballet des
véhicules est incessant il rassure
autant qu'il inquiète
écoutez bien sûr nous avons des petits
enfants des enfants
donc comment peut-on ne pas s'inquiéter
vous comprenez comment ne pas être
inquiet j'ai trois petits enfants ici ne
serait ce pas inquiet comment ne pas
l'être
comme beaucoup dans la région cet
habitant de castagnès est avant tout en
colère contre l'union européenne un
sentiment d'abandon partagé par un des
habitués de son café je veux dire une
chose
pourquoi les réfugiés ne vient-il qu'en
grèce pourquoi n'y at il pas dans un
autre pays
pourquoi seulement en grèce les turcs
les envoie ici
pourquoi ne pouvons nous pas les envoyer
par exemple en france en italie en
allemagne dans d'autres pays
pourquoi pas pourquoi leurs frontières
sont elles fermées encore hanté par la
crise migratoire de 2015 l'inquiétude de
la population locale grandi et les
associations humanitaires sur place
appelle à une action rapide
l'évadé n'est pas juste de se décharger
sur les épaules des grecs et de leur
renvoyer toute responsabilité il est
temps pour l'union européenne d'engager
un dialogue et de trouver des solutions
à ces problématiques que l'on observe en
grèce mais aussi en italie et en espagne
ici il n'est pas rare de voir errer sur
le bord de la route des migrants qui ont
réussi à échapper à la surveillance de
la police grecque
des milices de citoyens se constituent
pour empêcher l'entrée des migrants dans
le pays
des milices largement soutenus et
encouragés par la population
voilà ce que nous les grecs faisons
toujours nous aidons l'armée mais le cas
échéant à nous ferions face à la
situation
l'union européenne
eux oui ce qui promettait de nous aider
je le faisais malheureusement quand
parole on ne nous voit aucune action de
leur part a mené une armée je ne sais
pas comment ils peuvent nous aider ils
nous ont dit nous vous aiderons on le
fera mais ils ne font rien mais d'accord
comme le dit un proverbe on va de
nouveau sortir le serpent de son trou
selon le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
soixante quinze mille personnes sont
arrivés en grèce en 2019 un afflux trop
important pour les personnes rencontrées
lors de ce tournage
tous nous ont confié avoir l'impression
d'être trahi par l'union européenne qui
les obligent aujourd'hui à porter un
fardeau qu'il juge trop lourd pour la
grèce
[Musique]